aujourd'hui je vous sélectionne 9
accessoires complètement fou que j'ai
trouvé sur Amazon pour mettre sur votre
smartphone si je comprends bien c'est un
projecteur qui va projeter un clavier je
prends ajouter au panier caméra
thermique infrarouge ça veut dire
qu'avec ça je vais pouvoir venir shooter
la nuit ouh ça me plaît ajouter au
panier manette de jeu pour Android ça me
permet de transformer mon smartphone en
une véritable console de jeux un
endoscope en 1080p wifi caméra ok ça
aussi j'ajoute au panier et puis étanche
support de douche que je peux me laver
en regardant mes vidéos j'ajoute aussi
au panier ventouses silicone pour
téléphone c'est quoi ça veut dire que je
poste saoudo disons 99 ça va je vous dis
si fort téléphone portable pour
ordinateur assez malin ça veut dire que
je peux venir poser à côté de mon mac ou
d'un PC ou peu importe bref et mon
téléphone je dois payer brassard
téléphone sport amovible 360° pour
iPhone ok microscope numérique Wi-Fi
grossissement x 50 à x 1000 ça ça me
bottes le dossier au panier autoscope
oreille HD caméra nettoyant oreille
portable avec cild oh pas très ragoutant
mais ok je te paye support téléphone
universel Lee téléphone portable oh le
truc de feignasse ça aussi j'ajoute au
panier et là on a un bâton à selfie
flexible pour chien ou chat j'adore la
tête du Caniche qui regarde je te paye
j'ai donc un panier avec 12 accessoires
722 euros le temps de le recevoir et on
va voir ce que ça raconte
si vous voulez vous faire un revival de
vos cours de sciences maths vous avez un
microscope Wi-Fi l'idée une fois de plus
pour votre smartphone c'est de se dire
on peut venir en faire un autre objet et
là le transformer en microscope ça peut
être marrant alors si comme moi vous
avez un enfant je pense que ça peut être
super cool de venir lui faire découvrir
des choses du vivant des insectes des
fleurs des plantes enfin bref ça ça
bourgade parce que vous voulez j'ai donc
le microscope qui est ici branché
directement à mon mac sur Mac il faut
utiliser l'application Photos boost ou
je vois exactement là en même temps ce
que j'ai ici donc là j'ai une petite
molette qui ne permet de faire la
netteté le lien modifié les LED plus ou
moins fort plus ou moins d'éclairage
donc là je suis sur une petite mousse
alors c'est quand même pas mal après on
va quand même la définition de la caméra
c'est pas foufou mais ça marche quand
même pas mal il faut aussi le faire sans
fil de faire directement sur mon
smartphone donc vous voyez là si je
bouge un peu je l'ai directement sur
smartphone donc là je peux venir tourner
à 180 degrés retourner ma résolution
peut changer je peux monter en poule HD
c'est plutôt cool je peux faire de la
vidéo donc là je peux balancer de la
vidéo et ah donc ça ça fait une photo en
fait moi ça marche ce truc donc là je
sais pas ça enregistre pas là et après
j'ai accès à
mon contenu voici quand j'appuie sur
vidéo ça enregistre quand même c'est le
soft qui est bizarre et pourquoi ils
appellent ça retraite retraite parce que
c'est pas à cause de mes cheveux blancs
qui va être tresse faut pas déconner
avec ça bref accessoire je trouve
si vous voulez pour vous amuser à
l'explorer le vivant vous avez tout en
direct pour aller découvrir la nature
pour le faire avec des des plus jeunes
avec des enfants je trouve ça juste
supra cool si vous intéresse je vous
mets un lien juste en bas dans la
description
vous y trouve un truc de fou pour chien
ça ça permettra de faire des photos de
votre chien sans aucun problème alors il
y a rien de technologie derrière c'est
en fait une petite pince je le prends je
le mets comme ça donc je prends un
biscotte je viens le positionner là
assis assis va bouger
sur le gâteau non pas bouger les gâteaux
et là j'ai une photo magnifique
[Musique]
avec l'accessoire je vais vous montrer
vous allez pouvoir transformer votre
smartphone en une vraie console de jeux
c'est grâce à ça ça c'est la Razer qui
suivait de pro vous connaissez Razer qui
est l'incontournable dans l'univers du
gaming et là avec la Clichy V2 Pro vous
poussez l'expérience de gaming sur
smartphone encore plus loin vous avez
une vraie manette de gaming que vous
venez poser sur vos smartphones fatigué
extensible ce qui est vachement cool
parce que vous allez pouvoir venir
mettre tous les smartphones que vous
voulez smartphone sur Android ici
uniquement on se branché ici directement
en bas vous le voyez sur une prise usb-c
la prise en main est confortable ce qui
fait que je tiens vachement bien en main
en plus de ça est-ce qui est génial
c'est que vous avez une prise jack en
bas à gauche et de l'autre côté en bas à
droite vous avez une prise usb-c qui
vous permet de jouer tout le smartphone
comme ça pas de risque il manquait de
batterie dans la journée et vous venez
télécharger l'application dédiée c'est
l'application Nexus et là vous avez
accès à tous vos jeux très facilement ce
qui est génial c'est que vous avez un
retour à petit donc vous sentez vraiment
quand ça va venir vibrer j'appuie sur Y
je l'active comme ça j'ai vraiment les
sensations de vibration directement
lorsque je joue ça c'est vachement bien
alors là hop les directement configuré
sur mon jeu autre point qui est cool
c'est que j'ai vachement de commande sur
cette manette la manette en marque des
micro switch Razer placé dans le dipad
les boutons et les gâchettes pour une
réactivité optimale si je vais faire une
capture d'écran et bien j'appuie sur le
bouton là hop là capture d'écran que je
pourrais venir partager avec ce bouton
là vous allez arriver dans le menu Nexus
directement ça me permet donc d'avoir
une console complète à la maison avec
toutes les applications je peux
retrouver sur le Play Store mais j'ai
également tout mon catalogue
d'application avec du cloud gaming vous
pouvez jouer au plus grand jeu triple A
directement sur votre smartphone Xbox
stimlink GeForce now PS remote play il y
a certains jeux où les commandes vont
pas être connues et bien ils vous
proposera ici une manette virtuelle
comme pour pubg par exemple et vous
allez venir mapper les commandes
directement dans votre jeu ce qui est
cool ici en plus c'est qu'on a une très
faible latence vous le prenez vous
l'emmener avec vous vous transportez sac
à dos grande poche que vous voulez cinq
bananes c'est à vous de voir bref c'est
vachement cool si vous êtes donc
amoureux de gaming et vous voulez jouer
sur smartphone pensez vraiment à cet
accessoire là qui est juste topissime
c'est la réservis de pro il existe
également la V2 sans les retours à petit
qui est aussi disponible pour Android et
iPhone et ça pour moi c'est un très
grand oui je trouve ça vraiment super
cool
j'ai trouvé un accessoire super marrant
c'est un endoscope ça permet de venir
voir dans des cavités dans des endroits
vous pouvez pas vous accéder directement
on va aller voir à l'intérieur ici on
toile d'araignée on va essayer de les
passer c'est
cool secte un garde-manger ce que ce
serait pas un garde-manger d'araignée
tout au hasard donc là je suis contre un
mur et là de ce côté donc là je vois
bien le trou tu as pas l'impression
qu'on fait l'aspectologie un peu donc là
on est sur des espèces de cailloux c'est
quoi ça c'est pas si c'est un boot ah
c'est une feuille regarde si une feuille
est venue jusqu'ici c'est qu'il y a un
insecte qui l'emmené ça garde la
j'avance la contre les toiles
d'araignées voilà la vache ça c'est quoi
ça c'est de la race espèce de roche là
c'est pas mal le point quand même hein
ça fait quand même un point qui est pas
dégueu donc bon on a pas croisé de bêtes
sauvage on a pas croisé d'araignée on a
vu qu'il y avait des feuilles à
l'intérieur par contre je suis vachement
bluffé par la définition qui est
franchement pas mal du tout ça c'est un
histoire qui est très cool pour aller
voir dans les canalisations ce qui
bloque dans les trous un peu bizarre on
peut partir explorer c'est semi-rigide
c'est pas mal donc ça aussi je valide
là je vous ai trouvé un accessoire qui
permet de venir poser son smartphone la
promesse normalement c'est que vous
pouvez le poser autour de votre coup
c'est un truc qui est rigide on va voir
si ça marche ça c'est quand même déjà à
la base très rigide j'ai un espèce de
stand je peux le mettre dans un sens ou
de l'eau donc si je veux regarder
Tic-Toc YouTube vous voyez c'est pas le
même délire je dois pouvoir le poser là
et ensuite je tire je suis un peu au max
là alors c'est quand même pas mal de
l'avoir comme ça parce que si je bouge
un peu forcément ça bouge un peu après
la distance elle est pas folle c'est à
dire qu'à un moment jusque quand même de
me flinguer un peu les yeux d'ailleurs
je vous ai fait une vidéo où je parle de
justement faire attention à vos yeux
mais si on veut un truc un peu en mode
feignant comme ça je suis dans le salon
et je veux pas le tenir à la main c'est
pratique je peux regarder mes vidéos en
marchant en même temps je vois où je
mets les pieds c'est quand même
vachement pratique et pour y regarder
les vidéos hop
le
lit je tourne et Tic-Toc après je peux
aussi venir le positionner dans la
cuisine ça ne sert très pied je peux
aussi bien faire ma vaisselle et
regarder un truc je peux aussi bien
cuisiner avoir accès à mes recettes donc
en fait comme c'est suffisamment rigide
je peux le mettre comme je veux et ça
c'est pratique
autre accessoire qui est marrant pour
votre ordinateur c'est ça ça c'est très
cool pourquoi parce que ça vous permet
de venir poser votre iPhone tout contre
votre Mac en fait c'est une espèce de
pince qui va venir se poser directement
sur votre Mac PC également donc là il
vient comme ça le smartphone avec ça je
viens je le repositionne je passe sur
mon Mac
comme ça d'un côté et de l'autre j'ai
mon smartphone j'ai mon ordi premier
regardez une vidéo en même temps que je
travaille enfin bref je vais faire plein
de choses donc c'est accessoire je le
trouve globalement assez marrant ça
l'incline en plus légèrement vers
l'ordinateur ce qui fait que ça vient de
centrer vers mon visage qui est à côté
donc c'est typiquement un accessoire que
je vais venir recommander
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé un truc super marrant pour
venir poser votre smartphone comme par
exemple dans la salle de bain vous
décidez de vous laver le visage de vous
raser que vous voulez regarder votre
écran en même temps en le posant sur
miroir et ben là j'ai un système collant
devant tous donc là vous avez derrière
le petit collant on l'enlève je vais le
poser au dos de mon iPhone c'est pas
grave à la place de la pomme si si ça se
met comme ça enfin je pense non tu crois
pas toi tu penses que ça se colle contre
la surface ça non
on va essayer maintenant la logique tu
as raison je le pose comme ça là tu as
raison de me reprendre mon coco quand je
dis n'importe quoi donc là je le pose là
voilà là je suis content j'ai ça et
maintenant j'ai qu'à prendre mon iphone
le poste comme ça là et maintenant j'ai
plus qu'à venir me mettre hop sur
Youtube et ouais mais alors je peux pas
changer de sens alors ça veut dire que
faut que je l'enlève je le mets comme ça
donc là je peux faire ça et en même
temps que je regarde ma tronche le mec
qui est juste mégalo qui se regarde en
même temps comme raser voilà
ah ouais vachement bien cette vidéo
inconvénient c'est que c'est en train de
se casser la gueule donc c'est avant
tout mais ça vend tous pas super
j'ai un autre accessoires qui vient du
futur c'est un boîtier qui va venir me
projeter un clavier je dois pouvoir
venir taper directement sur mon bureau
et ça me servira clavier hop alors
faites voir comment ça marche le truc
[Musique]
coucou
c'est ouf forcément j'ai mis la lumière
ça va un peu moins bien se voir mais moi
je vois quand même pas trop mal donc
j'ai une petite doc avec Wims que si je
fais FN que j'appuie sur là je peux
monter la luminosité mais non je suis
déjà à fond je peux la baisser mais je
peux plus grand chose je suis très
heureux mon lapin c'est vrai
non et fume moment later je suis super
heureux d'utiliser un truc levier c'est
vraiment que c'est absolument ridicule
le clavier laser c'est chouette mais ça
sera non
c'est l'heure de la douche vous voulez
regarder votre smartphone lorsque vous
êtes en train de vous laver vous la
regardez l'actualité des films quand
vous prenez un bain ou quoi que ce soit
c'est un accessoire que je vais pouvoir
venir poser et qui normalement va venir
protéger mon smartphone contre la flotte
il nous donne une petite lingette pour
venir protéger ma surface deux accroches
c'est pas mal pour une position debout
et pour une position je suis dans mon
bain je pensais que c'était une lingette
mais c'est peut-être pas une lingette
Cologne do not it
pour venir se parfumer c'est sympa je
vais sortir l'autre Cologne comme tapis
donc là je vais me dire hop je vais
mettre mon premier écran ici pour venir
nettoyer avec un chiffon pas avec sa
main on pose un dans cette position et
j'en mets un autre dans cette position
là ensuite vous prenez votre smartphone
que vous mettez dedans en mettant
ça quand même on prend son smartphone ou
on va mettre un petit YouTube
normalement le tactile à mon avis il
marche plus après je vais venir le
glisser dedans normalement voilà c'est
un peu étouffé mais ça marche
alors regarde il y a un truc tactile je
pense qu'il y a un truc tactile quand
même sur la vente smartphone
c'est tactile
ah c'est génial je peux mettre la poche
je peux mettre lecture ça veut dire que
par contre ça craint un peu les gouttes
mais ça reste totalement étanche donc
quand je me mette en position douche ou
en position baignoire je suis quand même
vachement pas mal comme ça je peux venir
regarder des films des séries tous les
contenus que je veux directement dans ma
douche et ça ça me rend heureux autre
point de détails puisqu'on se parle de
la salle de bain vous avez des petites
trucs que vous venez ouvrir en fait sont
des crochets et les crochets sont malins
pourquoi parce que lorsque vous posez
comme ça et bien vous pouvez venir poser
un gant de toilette en bas donc en même
temps tac je pose mon gant à droite je
pose mon bras gauche ça me sert un peu
d'accessoire dans la salle de bain
on a l'autoscope qui vous permet de
savoir exactement ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de votre oreille l'intérieur
de votre oreille ou de votre nez alors
l'idée c'est de venir nettoyer parce que
vous avez en fait sur cette partie là
une espèce de petite curette qui va
venir curer à l'intérieur de votre
oreille alors le truc qui est pratique
c'est que dans votre boîte et bien vous
avez plein d'autres curettes parce que
fatalement va utiliser plusieurs fois
pour venir nettoyer votre oreille autant
que vous avez besoin vous avez une
application que vous téléchargez et dans
votre application et bien vous voyez ce
qui se passe dans votre caméra pour
venir lancer une vidéo par exemple j'ai
un espèce d'énormes poils à l'entrée de
l'oreille coucou toi on va l'appeler
Patrice ça Patrice le poil et là on voit
quand même que j'ai pas trop mal bossé
je peux rentrer un peu plus dedans faut
que je fasse il y a un truc de détection
du tympan pour pas venir par cette
tympans et aïe il faut faire vachement
bien que ça je vais curé un peu je vais
quand même en train de me curer
l'oreille en direct sur YouTube ah là
c'est quoi là ah tiens voilà un pote de
Patrice alors c'est Patrice qui est de
retour il y a pas trop de petits copains
jaune là dedans j'ai quand même bien
travaillé voilà on peut pas voir
beaucoup mieux après je veux pas me
faire mal on va regarder de l'autre côté
j'ai un pote de Patrice qui est là là ça
doit être son cousin ça doit être
Rodrigue c'est quand même dingue de me
dire que j'ai un accessoire pour
smartphone qui me permet d'aller voir à
l'intérieur de mon oreille là vous voyez
dès que j'arrive là je suis vachement
plus sensible je le sens plus donc je
vais pas aller plus loin toute façon
l'idée de venir se nettoyer l'oreille
alors avec ça ou avec ça c'est d'enlever
tout ce qui va être en cérumen en
superficie et pas se faire mal donc là
je peux enlever après quand j'ai fini
mon petit embout faut que je le tourne
voilà je l'enlève et après on peut
partir l'exploration oh mon dieu c'est
dégueulasse c'est quand même assez
bizarre comme accessoire pour smartphone
mais je trouve ça assez malin mais
faites vraiment attention mais vraiment
super attention à pas venir vous
flinguer les oreilles à pas aller trop
loin ce serait quand même compte de
venir se percer le tympan à cause d'un
petit objet plutôt marrant
l'accessoire pour voir dans le noir est
arrivé juste là c'est une caméra
thermique à venir ajouter à votre iPhone
alors il existe une version également
spécialement conçue pour Android on
prend on ouvre on va se retrouver avec
ça à l'intérieur la petite caméra
thermique que je vais pouvoir poser un
tout petit accessoire je la plug ici
j'ai aussi une application qu'il faut
que je vienne télécharger donc là
normalement on doit voir mon coco qui
est en train de filmer je vois que là
sur le front là je suis à 37 degrés là
je suis à 36,8 36,5 34 7 derrière là je
suis à 28 9 il fait chaud dans la PC là
on voit le micro je vois bien qu'il y a
une source de chaleur au niveau de la
lumière là on voit bien la main devant
elle a combien la lumière elle fait 29
degrés 7 là tu es à 35 degrés là là
c'est à 32 33 degrés ça là il y a le
téléphone là le Z flip là j'ai un truc
chaud là ah vache je vois la température
sur la table qui a chauffé là là ça a
chauffé et même quand je descends la
vache regarde je pose ma main j'enlève
j'ai les traces de la main
waouh j'adore ça veut dire que je peux
écrire un truc que tu ne verras pas
j'écris des messages qui disparaissent
c'est ouf par contre ce qu'on voit c'est
que la partie ici l'optique elle est
plus sombre alors je vois que là j'ai
une fenêtre qui est fermée forcément il
fait vachement chaud moi ce qui me
bluffe c'est là j'ai le téléphone je
déplace le téléphone et j'ai encore la
marque du téléphone et j'ai encore la
main tout à l'heure et j'ai encore un
peu la marque des mains les beaux gosses
quand même comme ça on s'en rend pas
compte mais
cet angle là tu es quand même plutôt
beau gosse et j'ai même la température
de ton corps donc je trouve ça vachement
cool donc si vous voulez un accessoire
hyper fun hyper fou pour votre
smartphone iPhone et Android et bien
vous pouvez aller sur une caméra
thermique la marque c'est top donc top
donne top don plutôt cool
accessoires pour smartphone de fou c'est
un micro de karaoké alors on peut dire
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire avec un micro
de karaoké en tant que ce soit pour
smartphone alors en fait si c'est bel et
bien un vrai accessoire pour smartphone
pourquoi parce qu'il se connecte en
Bluetooth à votre smartphone et ensuite
vous avez plus qu'à me dire chanter
dedans comme ça vous avez la musique
directement allez là on va se mettre un
petit morceau de blues si on nous a
présenté France on a chanté juste
j'aime bien faire des vidéos oh oui je
ne chante pas faux on apprend total à la
maison on est pas mal
en me faut total on sait chanter on se
fait pas mal j'ai un bouton là là je
peux venir changer
ok
let's go de blues comment elles sont
baisser tu as fond là je crois ok tu
peux baisser le son
maintenant que je suis bien ridicule
vous avez vu qu'il existe un accessoire
pour smartphone qui permet de chanter le
micro karaoké donc voilà ça vient
compléter ma sélection
pour les amoureux de sport vous avez
trouvé un espèce de petit bracelet qu'on
va venir poser ici c'est pas moi un
bracelet un bracelet à 360 degrés design
alors je connaissais le principe de le
mettre là je connaissais pas le principe
de le mettre là donc je me suis dit que
bon c'est pas un truc qui est tout
nouveau mais ça pouvait être
relativement marrant ça déjà je viens de
le mettre autour de mon téléphone sur le
14 pro max c'est violent j'ai
l'impression d'avoir mis un string avant
smartphone donc ça c'est le brassard que
je vais venir mettre comme ça là et
ensuite je le prends je viens de glisser
là je peux venir normalement le tourner
à 360 je trouve ça un peu gros sur
l'avant-bras je suis pas sûr que ce soit
la bonne idée je sais pas si je pourrais
courir comme ça pendant des heures tu
vois je fais mon running je pense que
c'est mieux ici parce que si tu le mets
là en fait tu vas avoir truc un peu plus
stable que là ça se déplace davantage et
c'est pas ouf je pense pas que ce soit
la solution la plus ergonomique pour
venir avoir un accessoire là je crois
qu'il y a une boîte française qui
s'appelle shape art qui fait ça et qu'il
le fait mieux donc bon voilà c'est
marrant mais sans plus dites-moi vous
quel est l'accessoire qui vous a le plus
plu moi je crois que c'est vraiment la
perche à selfie pour chien qui m'a fait
le plus marrer après il y a aussi
l'accessoires pour venir poser son
smartphone et regarder directement
devant ça c'est marrant d'ailleurs une
fois de plus penser à protéger vos œufs
je vous ai fait une vidéo d'ailleurs des
sept erreurs qu'on fait tous on ne vient
pas assez se protéger les yeux la vidéo
est juste là foncez la voir et vos yeux
vous diront merci j'ai un autre
accessoire qui vient du futur